hi my name is avinash and welcome to the
web analytics course we're very excited
to cover some of the basics when it
comes to web analytics and the very
first one
perhaps is why do you need
to do wireless if you're doing anything
on the web
for the longest amount of time we have
made very
faith-based decisions when it comes to
our marketing our customer service our
advertising and other kinds of
activities that companies do and a lot
of it was dictated by the fact that we
didn't actually have access to a lot of
data
it was or it was very difficult to get
data but one of the coolest things about
the web is that you actually have access
to near infinite amounts of data
usually not for a lot and
so one of the reasons that you want to
use web analytics for is that
the simple act of of adding a tag to
your website allows you to have access
to an enormous amount of consumer
behavior when it comes to your digital
existence that means that you get a
really deep understanding of what is
working what is not working what do
consumers like what don't they like
where do they come from where do they
not come from and other kinds of things
and it allows your company to make very
smart decisions for example if somebody
walks into a chevy dealership
here in santa cruz you probably have
very little idea about what caused that
person to come to the chevy dealership
but if somebody lands on chevy.com on
the other hand
they bring with them a lot of trace of
what caused them to come and engage with
you
for example they might have searched on
google for a particular keyword and now
you have access to that insight or they
might have come in response to
television commercial that you ran and
visit your website and you have access
to that so a lot of this is
a really great way to understand
effectiveness of how you spend your
money which in turn helps you
do very smart things when it comes to
your consumers
not only that but it also opens the mind
of your organization much wider maybe
you believe that the only thing you can
do on the chevy website is give
information that drives people to the
dealer but in reality people who will
engage with you online are going to be
there not only to
go figure out where the nearest dealer
is but they could be existing customers
looking for help or it could be car
enthusiasts who want to
customize their cars and trick them out
is play around
for and configure a car they might want
to buy six nine months from now or they
might just be people who want to
understand a lot more about chevrolet's
philanthropic efforts and at the moment
all of these things are very difficult
to be met in an offline world but with
online you can and that's where web
analytics plays a really key role
helping you understand why people come
to your website once they are there what
is it that they do and at the end of it
do they leave happy and did you make
money both of those questions get
answered very quickly
so now that you're very excited about
web analytics let me formally define
what web analytics actually is
and in my books the way that i have
defined web analytics is it's the
analysis of qualitative and quantitative
data about your website and your
competition to drive continuous
improvement about your digital presence
your customer needs and prospects which
translates into great and fabulous
desired outcomes both online and offline
for your business that's more of a
formal definition of web analytics and
let me let me sort of cover a couple of
these pieces that are really really
important and the very first one is very
often web analytics is mistakenly
believed to be just the art of logging
into google analytics or adobe web
trends or ibm and analyzing all the
quantitative data you have related to
the clicks
and that is indeed a big component of
robotics is all about but it's also
about answering the question about why
people do what they do and that's where
sort of qualitative analysis around
surveys and usability tests and those
things come into equation one of the
cool things about the web is not only
can you analyze your own performance we
can actually analyze how your
competitors are doing which is very very
cool
there are paid tools that you can use
there are
free tools you can use but if you're
competing with somebody on the web you
can actually go get their data and you
can go understand how they are
successful or not and learn lessons from
what they are doing and go figure out
how to change your strategy in turn
it's also very important to understand
that
you can serve the needs of people who
want to buy from you right away or
donate money from you right away but
also people who are in the process of
just considering and that's the
difference between kind of people are
very close to becoming customers versus
people who are going to be prospects
it's going to take them a while to get
converted
and the last thing of course is all
about understanding that web analytics
does not simply affect what you do on
the web on mobile phones tablets or
desktop and laptops but actually what
happens to your offline existence if you
have a call center that will be
including web analytics if you have an
actual supermarket store or dealership
those things would be included so web
analytics at it at its holistic level
is the art and science of qualitative
quantitative analysis of your data and
your competition's data in order to
drive improvements to the consumer
experience online and to drive business
outcomes online and offline and that's
what makes it so very exciting